[Music]
[Applause]
need some content
andy staples covers college football for
the athletic and before we get to the
potential for a playoff here
andy let me ask you about these
quarterbacks the biggest
question mark you have with the
quarterbacks
is attached to who trey lance sample
size and that's really it because he's
got everything else i mean he's got
everything you want in terms of size
speed arm strength
football iq all that stuff but he's
played one season in the fcs as a
starter
and that's that's the issue you know you
say mack jones only played one season as
a starter and justin fields played
one and then an abbreviated season but
they were playing in the sec in the big
ten
justin fields are trey lance was playing
in the fcs
so that's really the big question and
the thing i would
i would want out of the team that drafts
trey lance is give him a chance to learn
you know give him kind of the
the pat mahomes redshirt treatment and
you know if that's the 49ers you could
probably do that with garoppolo
but you know i i'm i'm in the camp that
says
that that kyle shanahan is looking at
mac jones and going oh here's a guy who
played in a
basically an nfl offense last year under
steve sarkesian
he can just he'll throw the ball where i
want him to throw the ball
and i like that so i i see that it's the
falcons at four that intrigue me like
if they're gonna take a quarterback or
if they're going to trade that spot to
somebody who's going to take a
quarterback
i think that makes it more interesting i
would love to see justin fields go to
the falcons
i would love to see a guy from atlanta
be the falcons i mean he would be an
icon
in atlanta if he leads them to a super
bowl
well they loved him so much in georgia
they let him transfer
to ohio state so arthur blank had
nothing to do with that
arthur blake did not make justin fields
go in on that fake punt
uh give me the quarterback though to
keep an eye on with all the quarterbacks
that you looked at this past year
i'm intrigued about kellen monde and
what nfl teams think of him because
this is a guy who's athletic he's got a
good arm he got better
every year at texas a m and you know
he's
coached very hard by by jimbo fisher uh
so personality wise he can
he can handle whatever you're gonna
throw at him and the question is can he
be a little bit more dynamic than than
what we saw at texas a m now
this year is interesting because he
again he got better
even though he lost his four best
receivers he had a couple guys opt out
right before the season started so
i think you know if you're picking in
the
second round and you're looking for
somebody who might be able to come in
and help you
he might be that guy all right let's
recap what you
and stuart mandel were tweeting fbs
commissioners considering expanding the
college football playoff from four
schools up to double-digit teams
with the quote from a source i sense 12
teams is building support
how far down the road are we on this
they've been talking about this for a
little while i mean this discussion
actually started
following the 2018 season and if you
remember the
the final college football playoff
rankings that season that's the one to
remember
ohio state didn't get in you know notre
dame got in
and so that that knocked out another bcs
or
power five conference and ohio state not
only didn't get in
they finished in the final rankings
behind georgia which had just
lost the sec championship game there's
that fake pun again sorry georgia fans
but that was when people looked at it
and said hey wait what's going on here
are
are we the big 10 the most powerful or
second most powerful conference in
college football
are we going to be shut out of this
thing multiple times because remember
they didn't get in 17
they didn't get in an 18 their champion
didn't get it in 16 but ohio state did
so you've got that then you've got the
pac-12 which hasn't gotten in since 16.
you got the big 12 which was the the
original
you know existential crisis we didn't
get in the playoff and people are just
thinking about this and going wait a
second why are we in a system where
we can just be knocked out in september
october
when we could have a system where
everybody plays and we keep everybody
engaged and
somebody from every league is getting in
and i also look at it when somebody says
well it renders the regular season
meaningless and he said no it doesn't
now it means more teams
the importance of the regular season if
you say 12 teams are going to make the
playoffs
if i make it now 20 schools
are involved in those with the chance to
be in the 12 team playoffs
if i you know look at college football
now how many get a chance to be in the
top four
we may have seven or eight now i can at
least double that
i might even triple that and it would
only be nine percent of college football
teams
that would make the playoffs the nfl was
40 percent of the nfl makes the playoffs
college football the bowl games will
mean something now
uh you could have secondary bowl games
that now have are elevated a little bit
here
i'm gonna stop i'm gonna stop you there
bowl games are done
other than the ones that are already
semi-finals they're done i mean they're
going to be bowl games because their
television product and people like
watching football on tv
but you're not putting those early
playoff games in bowls you're putting
them where they belong on campus
you know so you're going to i want to
see okay so you're going to yeah i want
to
oh yeah that's what espn wants that's
what the schools want because
think about this if you're an athletic
director and you're trying to sell
season tickets wait you want to have a
full
yeah what and what's gonna sell you more
season tickets
priority to to buy tickets to a home
playoff game
or that buy game that you're probably
gonna end up getting rid of
okay yeah that makes sense give give me
the options that are
in play here it now is it just there's a
lot
okay yeah they're looking i mean they've
said they're looking at six
eight 10 12 16. i think realistically
they were taught
8 10 12 are probably what they're what
they're looking at eight is very neat
it's a multiple of four you have three
rounds quarter finals on campus and my
finals at bowls
neutral site championship game uh 10 and
12 then you add another week
but you add buys which i i some i was
always an eight guy
and i had an a.d text me out of the blue
a few months ago with with
an idea of 12. and i was like why that's
is that that seems like too many and
this person's like
no you're protecting the regular season
by putting in the buys and by putting in
the hosting so you know it matters if
you're one through four because you get
a buy
it matters if you're five through eight
because you host the game it matters if
you're nine through 12 because
you either get in or you don't that's a
lot more engaged fan bases
and engaged teams you know because one
of the big arguments is
if you do this does it nullify the
conference championship games
well let's look at what would happen so
the pac-12 conference championship game
which is not
really relevant most years like last
year usc and oregon
they're playing for a championship and a
trip to whatever
but this time it'd be for a playoff
appearance so that is a huge
huge game i mean it that has stakes
everybody wants to watch that
because the you know the the team that's
going to play them wants to see who
who they're going to play and then the
sec championship game okay i don't know
if alabama had much motivation because
if they lost they might still be in the
top four
but for florida if they win they would
have gone into the top four
so they not only would have gotten a buy
they would have gotten a home game
so there's motivation there are you
looking at
the power five conferences will get
automatic entry here
i would think so and i i would think you
can't do this
without if you're going to 10 or 12 you
got to give
an auto bid to the the highest ranked
group of five champion two
the cincinnati or the ucf or the boise
state or whoever that is
because that's just good for business
that's a lot of fan bases that stay more
interested in the sport
who don't feel like they're completely
shut out of the the race for the
championship now
do those teams have a chance to win the
championship would they
would they win potentially four games in
a playoff and went
probably not but i guarantee you the
first time one of them wins a game
this becomes the most beloved sporting
event in america
how soon can this happen so the soonest
it could probably happen would be
going into the 2023 season the the the
contract as currently constituted runs
through the end of the 25 season
but the the rotation of the bowls where
you have you know rose and sugar or a
semi and then and then fiesta and
and peach or a semi that starts again in
2023 so you could you could rip some
stuff up and do it then
that that would be the earliest good
stuff hey thanks for giving me some
content today
you know this is this is great what do
you got
we appreciate it too thank you
commissioners because we were getting
bored
yeah uh thank you andy great to talk to
you buddy
andy staples covers college football for
the athletic